hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round three of
the video world cup 2021 we are in the
rapids now
uh because the two classical games that
these two gentlemen played ended in uh
in a draw uh prague won the first game
and krasenko won the second one so now
they of course go into rapid tie breaks
and here
uh well it's a very interesting one also
the i think this is the first game of
the rapids but i will
check uh you know sometimes i um
i mess it up so let me just check real
quickly
uh yeah let's see this one
[Music]
all right
yes this is the this is the first game
of the rapid so it's a very enjoyable
one a lot of you have requested it
uh so let's check it out and see uh who
who will triumph so prague
with the white pieces opens with uh b3
and now
it's not only it's not only adiban who
is playing b3 it's everyone who's
playing b3 so now
nowadays you can't really play chess
anywhere and not be
prepared for b3 and if you've ever tried
to
uh well get some ideas uh on how to play
against b3 usually you'll see d5
e5 knight to f6 so many things are
possible here knight to c6 so basically
any move
but mostly grabbing the center because
it's a principle decision
since white uh i decided not to grab the
center right away with your pawns
black might be inclined to do so but
white will do the hyper modern thing and
will control the center with his pieces
so here we have e5 by krasenko bishop to
b2 and
now d6 so c4 white getting a nice
development here on the queen side
and krasenkov uh placing his pawns on
dark squares at the counter prague
strong bishop on b2 so g6 we have d for
now
and knight the d7 uh and here uh there
is
one game where g3 was played uh but
prague goes d
captures on e5 and it is already as of
move five that we have a completely new
game
so let's see how krasenko continues he
plays d captures on e5 and
now knight to f3 simple chess is often
the most
difficult to chest and now simply
developing with an attack on the e5
pawn black now also will do the same he
develops while defending
with e3 preparing to develop the light
square bishop and
knight the e7 now and the plus side
for developing your knights here instead
of an f6 and c6 yes for the moment you
do control less squares
uh but on the other hand at any point
you're welcome to play c5
or f5 and your knights will not be in
the way of your pawns
so here at bishop to e2 we have castles
by black and queen to d2 now
uh we have c6 uh now you could play f5
at any point
but krasenko for a moment uh keeping it
cool we have knight to c3 and
knight to c5 now offering a queen trade
and prague says all right we can trade
queens but
we'll trade queens if you want to
capture then i'm going to get a very
active rook here i'm probably going to
castle
and then bring the other rook to d1 with
nicely double double rooks and the
only open d file on the board so queen
to b6 krasenko not want to easily
trade queens as you've seen he's quite
the attacker and
bishop to a3 now not allowing this
knight to move as the
knight on e7 would hang and you have to
keep in mind moves like b4 are coming so
here rook to e8
and b4 now uh we have knight to e6 uh
instead of knight to e6 if you had more
time to calculate like i said this is a
rapid game
queen to a6 is very interesting saying
okay you can capture here i'm gonna
capture your bishop
and once the bishop moves back maybe e4
this may be something that would better
fit krasenkov style
but maybe if it was a classical game so
here instead of b4 we have knight to e6
going back with the knight
and now white castle so now you can see
that at some point
white will probably play c five knights
to e4 try to get an outpost for his
knight on d6
and black will try everything to prevent
this of course so rook to d8 grabbing
hold of the
d file attacking white's queen queen to
c2 and now
bishop to d7 so there's the question of
the light square bishop you have to
develop it somehow
and for the moment the only active
square is the d7 square we have queen to
b3
now defending these spawns and now the
bishop wants to get back to this
diagonal there's really nothing for you
to do on
on this one and now the queen helps out
with the defense of the b4 pawn at some
point c5 will be played
so first knight to f5 and now comes
knight to e4 so now
the knight helps out with the defense of
the d6 square and the
white would very happily play g4 to just
kick it away and get his knight all the
way to d6
so krasenkov stops this he plays h5 and
now
bishop back to b2 so again with a double
attack on the e5 pawn we have queen back
to c7 defending and now
c5 so uh prague definitely controlling
more space here and it's not that easy
for black to find
uh good squares for his pieces so here
we have b6 trying to attack white's
advanced pawn here and maybe even
overextended but we'll see prague
disagrees
uh we have bishop to c3 now as the uh
idaho can come to b8 and you don't want
your queen and bishop on the same file
so bishop to c3
and now b captures in c5 we have b
captures and now
rook d to b8 you could also play rook uh
8 to b8 but probably queen is coming to
a3 so maybe you just want to
keep the rook there to stay defending
the a7 pawn so rook d
the b8 attacking the queen queen to a3
and now a5 and it seems like uh
black's position is uh very much
playable but
uh in all truth it's uh completely lost
and there are
plenty of ways you can you can prove
this prague
goes for uh well for a very natural one
he plays bishop to c4 but
the the immediate forcing knight
captures on e5 is also very enjoyable
uh because it's uh black just falls
apart
uh even though you're defending this
twice but the
uh the black queen is uh just over
committed uh
the queen cannot keep an eye on e5 and
on d7 and the bishop on d7 is only
guarded by the queen
so here with bishop captures we're just
going to capture uh
the piece here attacking the queen and
if queen captures bishop captures here
and now we're also gonna pick up the
rook because black has no time to defend
it
knight to f6 check would win the queen
so you have to prevent
the loss of the queen and then we're
just gonna pick up the rook or we don't
even have to pick up the rook if
let's say queen to a7 we can play knight
f6 check and after the king moves now we
can
uh well we could pick up the rook we
could start mounting the attack queen c3
rook d1 rook c1
a lot of possibilities but uh prague
goes for the
uh line that requires uh less
less uh consuming of time as this is a
rapid game
so bishop to c4 and now we have f6 so
defending this e5 pawn not allowing any
tricks
using this knight captures on e5 but now
you've opened up this diagonal and you
can see that the progress bishop pair is
more than fully operational okay
the dark square bishop has some material
here that he needs to take care of first
but
it's looking very nice for progress
bishops so here we have
h3 now preparing g4 you want to get this
side away from f5 and now kink the h8
simply getting out of this pin
we have g4 captures captures and now
knight to h6 and now
rook to d6 so simply uh going for a
double attack here on the knight
and the problem is you can't really move
it because then the f6 pawn falls and
then again let's say
the fed knight captures here and again
black's entire position falls apart we
we got rid of everything in the way of
our dark square bishop and now our dark
square bishop will also become a monster
and also uh there's always the very
nasty king g2 rook to h1 so
attacking potential all over the world
you don't even need the queen progress
queen is on
a3 doing pretty much nothing here no
no the queen is doing absolutely nothing
here but uh influencing the entire game
from from the beginning something morphe
was for example famous off
so after rook to d6 we have knight
captures on g4
trying to stir some trouble saying okay
maybe you can capture and then i'm going
to do something who knows what krasenko
had in mind
but prague says no there's there's no
need to capture the material right away
just king g2
going after rook to h1 it's a move
you'll have to play the bishop car
will cover the g8 square so this knight
can't really move so here
we have knight the f8 preparing knight
to h7
rook to h1 check and now knight to h7
and now white simply starts uh picking
the black position apart
knight captures on f6 even though the
square is defended many times but it
doesn't matter
bishop captures on f6 but now prague
even plays rook captures in f6 and now
with this rook captures on f6 we've
removed all of the defenders of this
diagonal and now
his dark square bishop becomes a monster
so knight captures an f6
bishop captures an e5 with an attack on
the queen the rook is also there
the knight is here we can't really
defend it if bishop captures this knight
can't move
so you don't really have a good move
here queen to d8 only move that kind of
prolongs the game to keep an eye on this
knight but now
knight to g5 going after this knight
here
and the only way to defend is to bring
the rook somehow here so we have to give
up this bishop with tempo
so bishop to h3 check and i think this
is the saddest moment in the game
on move 33 because this light square
bishop of black
did nothing for the entire game it was
simply a problem it was uh you know the
the source of all of white's tactics
that f6 move had to be played in order
to somehow guard this bishop
that couldn't be developed and it it
just you know
shows you how important it is to develop
your light square bishop properly
because now
all this bishop ever did was now
sacrifice itself uh for this rook to
come into the game but this only
prolongs the game
so rook captures on h3 now rook to b7
okay the outer row comes into the game
defending the knight here
but now the position is completely
winning for prague uh there are
a lot of moves that win there are a lot
of really awesome moves that win so feel
free to pause the video
here and try to find any of the moves
that win for prague try to find the
coolest one
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding
any of the queen moves here and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's really
most of the queen moves probably played
queen to c3 and it was in this position
that krasenko resigned to the game
uh because all of the lines are pretty
much the same there's really no good way
to defend
the knight here but i just wanted to
point out that there are several
really awesome options because queen to
d3
uh offering the queen here works just as
well and
even my favorite is queen to b2 just
offering the queen straight up
because black could prolong the game in
a in a nice way by playing kink the
g7 in some lines but here if you do this
you can you know just to go after the
rook
and of course if the queen is captured
then just bishop captures on f6
uh sorry not bishop captures on f6 rook
captures on h7 and this is checkmate the
bishop
covers the g8 square and if the rook
doesn't move you could maybe play rook
to g7 or something it doesn't really
matter just bishop captures on f6
and that's it there's nothing that you
can play here it's just uh well
uh it's just uh uh often often the cases
is just too ugly to look at even
uh so after this queen the c3 move uh
krasenko resigned and prague wins this
brilliant
brilliant game and he also won the next
game in the rapids with the black pieces
so this means that prague goes into
round four of the
uh uh of the world cup uh and we'll see
what happens there so there are many
many games that are being played there
are many great games so thank you for
using hashtag
suggestion for uh also helping me try to
locate them i have one very specific
game in mind that i will show next
uh but if any of you guys have you know
some some of your favorites do use
hashtag suggestions so it's easier for
me to
to see it uh so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it really
amazing showing by both of them cresenko
really really uh did an outstanding job
of fighting such a such a young player
like like prague
with such uh dangerous chess but in the
end prague prevailed uh
so congratulations to the to the young
fellow uh so yeah once again i hope you
guys enjoyed that
i would like to thank hey kovanecki
happy birthday to jj from pp steven
winforth
matthew parker and tom derlow for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day